there's this veneer of media objectivity
um
where it's like nothing to see here
don't worry about it where objective
we're objective
and then the ownership structure is
completely changed you have the more
successful national media organizations
that have become polarized because
of audience share generally like if you
decide to become
a little more partisan then you can
actually get a more consistent audience
what's partly so frustrating is in
addition to the bias that it exists
but that there's a certain invisibility
to the bias among
mainstream corporate outlets right so i
will often hear people say if i tweet
out an intercept article
oh gosh that's your that's your source
for saying x y and z i'm not gonna
believe it
which is kind of the opposite of what
you should be
thinking
[Music]
happy holidays and merry christmas for
those who celebrate
from the yang speaks family this is zach
rahman one of the co-hosts of this
podcast with andrew
welcoming you to a special holiday
episode of yang speaks
i hope you guys have all had some time
to relax and enjoy it's been a crazy
slash
rough year and hopefully you've been
able to relax watch some movies drink
some eggnog
if you like eggnog i don't but i guess
people do um
but hope you enjoy your holiday look
we've got a special episode today
brianna joy gray
is joining with andrew brianna was the
national press secretary for bernie
sanders in 2020 she's also
a former member of the media having
worked as an editor for current affairs
and a senior politics editor for the
intercept she's got this interesting
perspective of
running for office in politics but also
in the media the one thing i will say
before you guys dive in is that i've
seen a lot of comments on twitter
depending who we bring on the episode
it's like oh you bring these people on
the right or you bring me people on the
left i don't like it and look that's
fine you're welcome to your opinion but
i just want you know we um
we do believe in humanity first we also
don't believe that if you bring someone
on your podcast you have to agree with
everything they say
we've had conservatives and we've had
far left liberals
um on yank speaks and andrew has gone on
their podcast as well
and i wanted to share with you of the
holidays that a friendly reminder
that we're all humans we are human
beings first and there's a lot more that
we share
than there is that we disagree about so
with that i hope you guys enjoy this
episode with brianna i wish you all a
very very happy holidays merry christmas
happy hanukkah whatever you celebrate
this is the time of year where we get to
pause relax and reflect
on who we love and what's special about
all of us um
as humans so love you guys enjoy this
episode of yang speaks
[Music]
i am so pumped to be sitting down with
bernie sanders national press secretary
powerhouse
extraordinaire brianna gray welcome brie
it's great to have you thank you andrew
it's a real pleasure thank you
is it okay if i call you brie is that
that your yeah of course i made my you
know i made my twitter handle back in
2009
uh because i was working somewhere where
they wanted me to do it they wanted me
to make a twitter account and teach them
how to how twitter worked because i was
like the young person on the staff
and so i made it bribry joy not really
thinking anything of it and now
you know over a decade later everyone
calls me brie but it's cool it seems it
feels familiar and comfortable and nice
so i like it
it is very familiar i can relate to your
twitter evolution
um so i'm a little bit older than you
which means that
that by twitter indoctrination um
happened a little bit later in life
um so for me what happened was i wrote a
book
in 2014 and the publisher was like hey
you need to be on twitter
and so i was like okay i guess i'll get
on twitter now so it was like 2013.
um and um you know i i
like having a social media account for
various platforms but i haven't been
very active
and then when i decided to run for
president then it became a much bigger
deal
so it sounds like it was similar for you
where 10 years ago you created this
account just to have it and then it
became this enormous deal when you
became this public figure
yeah i didn't i didn't use it at all
until 2015
2016 um because i was you know big mad
online
about progressive issues not getting the
hearing that i thought they should in
the context of the bernie campaign so
uh to make something anyone's ever mad
at me for being too online you can
blame bernie sanders being too online is
a real problem
because there are so many times i wind
up in like an online
um rabbit hole or vortex and i'm just
like what am i doing
like this is not what i should be doing
with my fine whatever day of the week it
is
um so i would love to hear about your uh
path and your evolution because i feel
like
everyone would want to be you in like
in multiple ways um but but you're
you're this leading progressive voice
there are so many people that in my view
uh are aligned with you believe what you
believe i think you would do
a fantastic job of arguing for your
point of view and doing it in a way
that's
uh very positive and effective uh so
can you share a little bit of your arc
uh
sort of how how you arrived at this
juncture yeah
um so i like a lot of
young people wasn't sure what i wanted
to do with my life i graduated in 2007
i was a history of science history of
art and architecture major so
no clear career path there i was one of
these people
who thought well i'm a good writer i
like to argue everyone's been telling me
i should be a lawyer so let me go ahead
and apply to law school
and you know after law school i still
wasn't entirely clear what i wanted to
do
so i you know just went to work for a
firm and figured i can
you know use the money to pay off my
loans and then have the flexibility
to take any kind of perhaps more
creative writing job that i really would
like to do
without the you know enormous six-figure
student loan debt on my shoulders but
like a lot of people in my age cohort we
got hit really hard by the
recession and kind of the bonuses and
job opportunities that i thought were
going to materialize
didn't i started um at my firm in
well i graduated law school in 2011. um
and should have started you know that
fall but a lot of us were deferred blah
blah blah anyway
um so i ended up working as a lawyer for
about seven years
uh struggling to pay down my debt but
when 2015 happened and 2016 happened and
bernie sanders was running
i found myself really frustrated by a
lot of the media narratives that were
going around in particular the idea
that he didn't have any diverse support
um
the reality was even back then that the
majority of people
under 30 of every demographic group and
across the gender spectrum
preferred bernie sanders i was 31 at the
time but i like to
lump myself into that i'll give it to
you for sure no probs
i'm a little ahead i'm a little ahead of
my my time generationally
um so i started tweeting a lot and my
you know 100 follower account started to
grow
and eventually i started a podcast um
called someone's wrong on the internet
because i was so frustrated with the
narratives that were going around and i
started it with
a friend of mine who's both gay and
korean-american because
of all of the narrative that was only
white people support bernie sanders
um and i said well let me start writing
articles to draw attention to this
podcast
where do you think that narrative
originated like was there a particular
media outlet that decided to throw that
out there
there was an initial article i forget
where it was i want to say
let me not guess i want to say politico
but that just might be my own um
bias that has emerged over a series of
kind of bias
um political takes from that particular
outlet but um
the the person who wrote the article
later said that they thought it had been
taken too far and kind of regrets
uh the trend but i think it was
something that was going to emerge no
matter what i don't know if you remember
from the the leaked podesta emails from
the hillary clinton emails
one of the exchanges that you saw was an
email from
um nira tandon who's now part of joe
biden's staff saying
we've got to get all of these
journalists of color and there was a
list of journalists
to really push this um to talk about the
fact that bernie has a bernie
bro problem that they could be helpful
in this regard so it really was a
top-down
approach to say let's exploit the fact
that democrats care about people of
color they care about diversity is one
of the main things that distinguishes
the party from republicans
and tried to pitch bernie's movement
as somehow uninclusive
anti-inclusivity when it was never
really the case and then in 2020 i think
we all saw
that bernie sanders and joe biden were
the only people who managed to really
get
above double digits with respect to
black voters bernie sanders was number
one with latino voters
um and bernie sanders was even number
one with black voters for a period of
time there in february
uh but you never really heard that in
the mainstream media and the narrative
persisted
despite the fact that you know bernie
raised more money
from black voters than had ever given to
a political
campaign in history more black voters
contributed to bernie campaign's
campaign than any other campaign
it's so is frustrating i can understand
that because
uh bernie 2015 was such a pure
messenger that i can see a lot of folks
of any
uh certainly any racial background um
getting behind it because like yeah i
remember watching bernie speak and being
like yeah every word he said was right
i was like yup that's right uh and
and somewhere around there i you know
sent him um you know donation because i
was like well if i think he's right then
i should
get behind him um so i know people a lot
of people felt that way
so what it sounds like you're suggesting
is that there was a political article
um and then some folks who supported
hillary clinton were like ooh let's make
some hay out of that
they decided like put it into the mood
i'm not sure that you know they
you know which which came first the
chicken of the egg i don't remember the
timeline of this place remember i was
just a civilian i was not involved in
politics
at all at this point what happened
you've gotten absorbed
oh what happened was i started writing
articles i started writing articles um
in order to draw attention to the
podcast and the articles themselves
really took off
and i started freelancing and i would
stay late at the the law firm and write
until midnight
um you know and you know or you know
right during my lunch break and stay
till midnight trying to make up for the
work that i should have been doing
one of the other i understand and
eventually that manifested in an offer
from the intercept to come on as a
senior politics editor at the start of
2018.
which was a dream for a massive paid cut
of approximately
75 percent it was a significant pay cut
i
i will say my my um erstwhile financial
advisor would not have advised me to do
that
um but it was literally my dream come
true and i had enough savings
in and this is you know my relative
privilege that privilege that enabled me
to do this
i had enough savings to basically take
the pay cut and eat through my savings
for a year while working at the
intercept
um and right as i had to make some
decisions about you know
whether to move and you know how to make
this work and how to refinance my loans
or whatever
i needed to do um i you know
i was reached out to by the bernie
campaign um in the beginning of 2019
about whether or not i wanted to come on
board as national press secretary and i
didn't resolve my financial problems but
it didn't mean that i would move to dc
i had to move anyway i had to get a
tuber apartment anyway um
and it was you know an opportunity that
i thought long and hard about
right because i enjoyed my independence
at the intercept
i understood how identity was going to
be weaponized in 2020 again and i
thought there was some benefit to having
an
independent journalist of color who was
a woman that's true
you know not you were doing good from
where you were and then you you know
uh-oh she has gone political
um so so uh
so it sounds like you were a full-time
journalist uh for
a little more year is that right a
little less than a year a little less
than a year
yeah so was that the dream come true was
that wonderful
that that period of time i loved it i
loved
working at the intercept i loved working
at a place where my politics were
validated and my
insights were really encouraged you know
i i had
friends at my law firm and i really
appreciated my experiences there as well
but
20 they're all miserable
[Laughter]
you know look the the the 2016 really
exposed the extent to which
we had very different um political
priorities
and people who i thought you know i was
in new york we all were you know
capital l liberal i thought we all
basically where did you grow up
sorry i should know this like were you a
new york area product originally or not
uh
yes and no that's a little bit of a
complicated story
i moved to new york when i was 15. um
but we had and i graduated from high
school in new york
but we had been living abroad for eight
years before that
uh abroad where we were in saudi arabia
for two years and then kenya for six
years
wow it's so cosmopolitan and you show up
in new york at age 15
yeah and it's just you know before that
um we had to living in north carolina my
mom was
in her um doctoral program at nc state
and we lived there for six years and my
youth but i was born in washington dc
where my parents met because they both
went to howard university
wow okay sorry thank you for that arc
that was very helpful to me
um so if you went to high school in new
york and then you worked there for
um eight years i mean you were very very
new york
um so then you moved to dc for the
bernie campaign how was that
you know um there's a lot
there's a lot to love about dc um mostly
i didn't get to experience it that much
because i was so just involved in
campaign life
and you know traveling a good amount of
time it wasn't as though i was kind of
meandering around the city and exploring
the way
i would like to frankly we're just doing
the dc food tour
right in the last year obviously it's
been kobe but since kovid i've actually
been able to walk around my neighborhood
more
get a better sense of the layout of the
city and i feel like i know it a lot
better than i did
when i was you know working during the
campaign season
i'm a huge fan of the intercepts
journalism everything i've seen out of
there
just seemed so real and on point
uh is different than other outlets that
way
and i think there's like a major problem
with what some people call
corporate media am one of those people
oh no i mean hey like i i like that as
moniker
it makes you think you're like yeah
corporate media and then you're like
what's the opposite of corporate media
so i i think the massive crisis in
journalism um you know
the first thing it's like a layer cake
and it's all terrible
um but the first layer is that over to
the local papers
have gone out of business and so if
you're in a community it's like no local
news like how that can you vote on
anything that's going on in your
community and then you have the national
media was completely polarized at
various directions
because your economic incentives drive
you that way
and then you have the social media layer
on top of it that describes you even
more to extremity even into like
different versions of reality where at
this point
it's like you know up is down left is
right you know
like vote totals or whatever we say they
are yeah well i have mixed feelings
about the
the um social media piece but to your
point about the the independent media
versus corporate media piece
you know there's a legitimate criticism
that can be made about the intercept's
funding model as well but there is a big
difference
when you have uh to the incentive
structure when you're working at a place
like the intercept where
you don't have requirements to get a
certain number of clicks or publish a
certain number of articles a day
um you can spend time doing research and
reporting without the kind of financial
pressures of
the typical ad revenue model because
it's funded by
you know a billionaire there's like a
large amount of money that's guaranteed
to the intercept to do its work
regardless of how much money
it makes um whereas other outlets tend
to have to make sure that this is one of
the good
this is one of the billionaires right
like well you know that's what i
when i say that there's a legitimate
criticism legitimate critique to be made
of the internet study model there are
pros and cons of that obviously but
there are firewalls up between the
intercept and um
the the ebay billionaire who's the one
that funds the intercept
um and there are a lot of on the record
i am a fan
of uh omidyar i think pierre omidyar has
done so much good work
not just the intercept but i ran a
non-profit for years and the omidyar
social fellows and the social innovation
investments
he's made i think the fact that he
already saw the problems with journalism
and was trying to do something about it
early on uh that there are
um legitimate criticisms of our winner
take all economic system but
in like in my mind omidyar is among the
most benevolent
uh wealthy people out there yeah i think
look the the point is not ever
in the critiques that come from the left
about the massive accumulation of wealth
etc
is not to say that any one individual is
you know
evil or that you know there aren't
people who can do good things with their
wealth the idea you know do you say
winner take all obviously um
uh a non-giorados wrote this great book
about this this idea
the idea is we shouldn't have to rely on
private charity
um to fix the problems of the world and
that the enormous accumulation of wealth
in the hands of very few people
can have really um um styming effects
for
journalism the fourth estate our
democracy you know the ability of
someone like
you know michael bloomberg who was what
the ninth richest person
on the planet to enter the race what
that means is that you know
he has the money to fund his famed
mayor's school right
where so many people were arguably
willing to endorse him and particularly
a lot of black mirrors it did seem like
a lot of mayors
were like bloomberg and you're like oh
maybe there's something going on there
yeah and it's not it's not again that
the mayors are bad people or like
you know wanting to do a bad thing but
if you go through as mayor's i had
nothing
for the record if i were mayor of a city
and mike bloomberg had
uh funded something in my city and then
decided to do something
you know like i i'm not mad at anyone
who said look the best thing for my
community
is for me to get on on board with this
campaign well here's the thing
you can there's it's one thing to to
critique the
system the system is that a lot of
mayors particularly these black mayors
from
poorer districts right who are from
predominantly minority districts who
have
a harder time raising money same goes
for black disproportionately black
congress people right who are similarly
coming from districts where it's harder
to earn money because they have a lower
income population
um for all the historical reasons that
we understand you know tend to be more
susceptible to these kinds of
buyouts and that's not because they're
worse people it's because of these
structural issues in terms of their
inability to raise funds and the fact
that when especially when you're a
congress person your number one job is
to raise funds for the party and there's
enormous pressures on you
to get that money so the critique is not
to say
you know keisha lance bottoms is a
problem is to say what can we do to make
it so
keisha lance bottoms is more free to
vote her conscience to reflect the
interest
of the people that she presides over um
her constituents instead of feeling the
need to take this money and then to give
an endorsement
i don't remember i thought keisha lance
bottoms was for joe but there was a
there were a number of other young
mayors there were sorry
yeah i'm sorry i didn't mean to like
throw her in particular under the bus
but she was the first
the first uh southern black black mayor
that came to mind she is very cool
um you know spent a lot of time in in
atlanta of late
so one of the things that people i don't
think um
make enough of bree is that at this
point
vast wealth often technology wealth and
the media have now
converged where you have these legacy
media properties that can't make money
or can't make enough money to keep
people happy
and so then some tech mogul titan
who does not like sports as much decides
to buy the publication
so mark benioff buys time magazine
jeff bezos buys the washington post
laureen powell jobs buys the atlantic
now some of these people i like uh you
know like
like some of them i like less
but but there's definitely a thing where
um where tech money and you
i guess you could use the intercept as
an example though we didn't buy it it's
not like a legacy media property that um
that omdr decided to buy um but there
has been this convergence
and i don't know if people this is
something that i
actually am very very frustrated by is
that there's this veneer of media
objectivity
um where it's like nothing to see here
don't worry about it where objective
we're objective
and then the ownership structure has
completely changed
there was a point when you had these
firms that were very profitable firms
you know newspapers even great business
for generations
uh and then that business has gotten
decimated so now
you have two thousand local papers out
of existence
over half of the papers that still exist
are owned by private equity so just like
ringing them for cash
and they don't really care about the
local coverage so much and then you have
the legacy publications that have often
gotten consolidated or brought up by
their individuals
or private equity or other firms and
then you have the more successful
national media organizations that have
become polarized because
of audience share
generally like if you decide to become a
little more partisan then you can
actually get a more consistent audience
yeah i think that's an accurate
diagnosis
and to your one of your first points
what's partly so frustrating is in
addition to the bias that it exists but
that there's a certain
invisibility to the bias among
mainstream
corporate outlets right so i will often
hear people say if i tweet out an
intercept article
oh gosh that's your that's your source
for saying x y and z i'm not gonna
believe it
which is kind of the opposite of what
you should be thinking
um you should trust a relatively more
independent outlet over
you know frankly the the new york times
i mean i
i know that it sounds people might be
tired of hearing about bernie bros and
media bias
um and i understand that but i'll tell
you
working um on the calm side and the
campaign
oh my gosh yeah that's true you have all
the inside scoop what the heck was going
on over there
you know the conversations that i was
having with people
in an effort to just say what had
happened right
so there was an episode where
um i was on the road uh bernie sanders
and all of the candidates i think almost
everybody maybe you were there andrew i
can't quite remember
had uh spoken at i believe an naacp
conference in detroit
and everybody spoke but
bernie sanders was the only candidate to
get a standing ovation from the room
and when i read the new york times
write-up of the event
uh the words bernie or andor sanders
were not mentioned once in this article
at the time bernie was a number two
candidate in the polls
right so i reached out to the author
this must have driven you
insane right especially given all of the
narrative around bernie having a black
problem right he's the only one at an
naacp conference who gets a standing
ovation from the room
so i reached out to the the writer who i
had recently met at netroots
and i thought we had a lovely talk and i
said hey i just wanted to you know reach
out and ask about why it was that bernie
wasn't mentioned especially since he did
so well and because he is
literally the number two and he's a
black audience
right and he said oh i must have been in
the bathroom when that happened
no way so so i said oh okay well the
footage went up immediately after you
know you could have watched it
you can watch your bathroom break
footage this is like a football game
where you have
you have tevo right and you know if you
were gonna time a bathroom
a bathroom break i perhaps would have
timed it not during
the number two candidate in the race's
remarks but you could wait till yang
yeah we all know that you were a dark
horse and people were sleeping on you
for too long
um but you know you know what you know i
think it's true
but you know his response at that point
was you know
not good and relatively hostile and he
pivoted to some other concerns he
thought
you know he thought that the campaign
had unfairly hit beat up on one of his
um colleagues because she had written a
piece that had gotten a lot of criticism
not from us but from the public because
it was not a great piece and i was like
well this isn't really my issue and
the conversation devolved but that kind
of thing happened again and again there
was another time
a journalist had written that bernie was
not not gonna make the debate after the
heart attack
that he was going to miss the next
debate after the heart attack it was
said declaratively like that
and so i reached out and said okay well
all the doctors are saying this kind of
procedure that he had usually has a
four-day recovery window
and people are back out on the golf
course or whatever and could you would
you mind
changing that um and he said no
absolutely not
uh i i'm just i'm not gonna i said on
what basis
you know this person has a doctor in
front of their name but they're not a
medical doctor i said you are not
your writer he was an editor your writer
should not be quoting you
as a source of medical expertise as to
when bernie sanders
can attend a debate and of course he was
at the debate
right so it was this kind of thing over
and over and over again you know bernie
wins nevada
and um chris matthews is talking about
how people are going to be
you know chopping heads off in central
park bernie you know bernie supposed to
be chopping people's heads off in
central park
there's no mention of the fact that he
got 70 of the latino vote and how
important latino vote was going to be in
the general election
right um you you had a person bringing a
swastika a nazi
flag to a burning rally and getting no
coverage but you know the use of some
snake emojis under other candidates
um you know instagram pages being a 45
minute
interview subject for rachel maddow you
know and on and on and on
and important things were happening
right the country was going into a
crisis toward the end of the primary
bernie sanders was standing there with a
lot of the answers and you know assad
has been championing
universal basic income we needed big
ticket ideas
to get us out of this crisis which we
all saw coming down the pike
by the end of the primary season and
right now
we are struggling we have gotten this
stimulus package now that is
half of what was being offered up prior
to the
election and none of the substantive
structural changes
that were on offer managed to make it
through the primary season
and it's it's demoralizing to have seen
such promise and inspiring ideas from
people like you
people like bernie people like elizabeth
warren and to see
none of that really reflected in our
party at present
your experiences on the bernie campaign
with the media
are reflective uh and so i i want to dig
into this uh
more because and i also don't want to be
like oh
you know like that like media this is
that
um but hearing your perspective is
fascinating
[Music]
all right if you're like me or let's say
like anybody
in this pandemic your mental health is
probably going for a
bit of a rollercoaster ride not being
able to see friends not be able to go
out
uh your job is probably different i know
these feelings i've had on myself
and it's one of the reasons why i'm
happy
to be sponsored by betterhelp for this
podcast because
they've got some really great tools and
a great tech platform to assist
you with this mental health challenge
we're all going through so betterhelp
will assess your needs and match you
with your own
licensed professional therapist so you
can connect in this kind of safe
very personal private online environment
it's very convenient and you can start
communicating you sign up you start
communicating another 24 hours pretty
cool so it's not really self-help it's
just professional
counseling so you can send a message to
your counselor any time
get timely thoughtful responses plus you
schedule weekly
video or phone session so you can kind
of do it at your own schedule
and you never have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room you don't
need to tell anybody
um it's honestly pretty great and it's
they've got licensed professionals for
anywhere and anything that includes
depression stress
anxiety relationships sleeping trauma
anger family conflicts
lgbt matters grief self-esteem for me it
was
energy and purpose um and frankly just
someone to talk to
it's great um everything and anything
you share is confidential and it's
convenient professional
and affordable so i want you guys to
check this out um
because they're our sponsor and we're
proud to be sponsored by them on this
podcast so
if you want to start living a happier
life today as a listener of yang speaks
because they're sponsoring us you get 10
off your first month by visiting
betterhelp.com
yang that's better help b t t e r
h e l p dot com slash yang join over one
million people
who've taken charge of their mental
health like me that's betterhelp.com
yang
so when you talk about corporate media
uh
sometimes it brings to mind for me it's
like okay
what is the uncorporate media like what
is a
source that you can actually just shrug
and say they don't have any incentives
around suppressing one candidate or
elevating another
uh and uh one outlet that people do
trust more than others um is
npr which is publicly funded uh you also
have c-span which is the most boring
thing in the world but it literally just
but it just like sticks a camera on
people and just like it lets them work
um
so i had a store like a time when i was
in a hotel in iowa after a day of
campaigning
and then i turned on tv and i was just
flipping channels then i saw c-span i
saw myself
and i was like like what's this that was
an event i'd done that day
and it was just presented without
commentary it was just me hanging out
with high school kids answering
questions
and i was like wow uh this is
up um at c-span uh
very very different than the cable news
coverage which has a completely
different rhythm
and presentation style so
if we were to want to mend journalism
like do you have any ideas uh like i
i think that there should be much more
public investment in journalism
i do not see any other way because right
now you have the corporate incentives
going one direction
and then in my mind it's either
philanthropy or public resources those
are really the only two
and the tech version is philanthropy
essentially because if you look at the
wealth and the people who care about
this it ends up
being techies very often um
and so if you don't love that and you
know their ups and downs to it like i
you know i think some of them do a great
job i'm
a fan of the atlantic's work like you
know i love the atlantic
um i think intercept is great work um
but then you pretty quickly land on
public uh support for journalism
and then there are a lot of folks that
are like oh you can't have the
government from journalism because
like you know it'll be corrupt orwellian
big brother like you know they'll like
censor everything and the rest of it and
you're like
well there is like the bbc which is
publicly funded and they seem okay you
have npr
seems okay you have uh you know
different
examples of this throughout the world
yeah so the
the conversation about kind of
government versus private funding is the
same conversation that ends up happening
about
between republicans and democrats about
big government versus all government
right and what what is missing from that
conversation often is like sure
hypothetically the government could have
could be corrupt
but we all know there's an enormous
amount of corruption
in the business world and there are no
democratic mechanisms for us to do
anything about that
so at least when we we have government
we have some semblance of
democracy still and we can vote people
in and out and have an accountability
mechanism
nobody really talks about okay we have
the free market how are we going to hold
jeff bezos who's richer than god
accountable for anything that he does to
any of his employees et cetera
but there's a third option right there
is independently
um subscriber-funded media that's
neither government or business based and
that's where you have outlets like
current affairs where i'm a contributing
editor you have outlets like
the intercept is partially independently
funded they are trying increasingly to
get off
of um peers funding and when people
subscribe it helps them to be able to do
that
um you have outlets like david sirota
who was my colleague on the campaign but
a veteran journalist of 20 years before
that
who started his own blog the daily
poster you have a lot of people
advocate for defecting from their
journalistic institution glenn greenwald
recently left the intercept to start his
own blog
um that is independently funded on
patreon where people
give money to these people you know to
these individuals
or in david's rhoda's case he's trying
to start not just an individual platform
but a platform where a lot of
progressive journalists can come and
write about
corruption and other kinds of issues
that get very little hearing
in the mainstream media but are really
at the root of a lot of the problems in
this country
through his outlet called the daily
poster so i do think that
people are finding a lot of interest in
this and it's a sustainable model
to a certain degree but if we are ever
going to be able to compete
with the msnbc's and cnns and fox news
of the world
i agree that something more substantial
has to change and i think
viewers demanding more of those
corporate institutions
would be really helpful because
currently i think the average american
believes that those that reporting out
of quote unquote liberal institutions
liberal
um media institutions is being done in
good faith
and they don't know that so many of like
msnbc
newscasters um pundits are conservative
they don't even know that some of the
people who are giving advice to the
democratic party on a daily basis
you know george bush's former comms
woman has a prime time spot at msnbc
you know fair vote in other
organizations that have assessed media
bias
show that the average msnbc panel is
skewed more conservative has more
republicans on it
than the average fox news panel you know
and so people are digesting this
information in good faith not even
really realizing
that the institutions that they think
are liberal and have a liberal bias and
that they want a liberal bias
aren't even liberal they are echoing the
same kinds of right-wing talking points
that you get on fox news
and in fact due to this kind of weird
populist surge that's happening
on the right sometimes you get a fox
news pundit who's more willing to talk
honestly about
something like trade policies or
health care even than some of the msnbc
hosts
there are two things i'd like to suggest
here one is
it's not left or right anymore it's kind
of
in the institution or outside the
institution and i love the folks like
you who are like trying to
like create the outside of the
institution
um ecosystem and voices the second thing
is that i love the subscriber model
um that you and others and just
to be like i don't know whether this is
true you're working at current affairs
as an editor
um are are you now at a point where
you're generating subscription for
yourself personally or
like are you working for a um a
publication
so i don't i don't get paid by current
affairs i'm kind of there as a
um you know an advisory in an advisory
role as a contributing editor and stuff
like that
i my income comes through my podcast bad
faith so
you know my co-host virgil texas and i
and he's from chapel trap house
check out bad faith it's a great podcast
i've been there
yes you have it's great everything is
worth your time and donation don't you
want to support brie
and virgil i appreciate that andrew
but yeah we you know the subscriber
model has worked
um you know for a relatively small sum
of money each month
people can unlock you know a ton of
premium episodes plus we put out a free
episode every week
um and they get a lens on the news that
they wouldn't
otherwise get now everyone you know
doesn't work
as well for everyone obviously we're
advantaged by the fact that we had
you know platforms because we knew who
we already yeah you're like national
voices and one
of the things that that too bree like i
i struggle with too because you know
you to yourself you're you uh but
you are remarkable virgil is very very
well known
and the fact that you can make it work
um
does not mean that you know like the
bottom whatever 90
some odd percent of folks could make it
work in the same way that's true
but but take take this into account i
was when i was a completely anonymous
citizen with 200 twitter followers i
started a podcast
and over the course of two years we got
to about
i don't know 8 000 people listening to
the podcast on average every week
every two weeks actually and and that
was that's that puts you in like the top
echelon of podcast the vast majority
of podcasts barely get anyone listening
to them ever
um and we have a lot of people listening
to this are like
you know like i mean that that sorry
that resembles reality it's true
continue i mean it's hard to break
throughs but we we managed to to break
through
to go viral a couple of times and we
never we never monetized the podcast but
i think that we
could have and we could have grown it we
ended up stopping it because i left and
went to the intercept
but the thing i will say about the
internet is that it has a democratizing
effect
i my political career to the extent that
i have one
came fully out of engaging with people
and having arguments and discussions
on the internet inviting people to
continue those conversations on the
podcast
writing articles that concretized my
views and were able to be disseminated
far and wide and went
viral on their own kind of merit not
because i was a
big name not because i was associated
with any institution my most viral
articles continue to come out of current
affairs magazine
i've never been published in the new
york times you know and so
i want to say yes it's hard but it's not
as hard as it would be if we didn't have
the freedom of these
internet platforms to get around a lot
of the gatekeeping that has
traditionally been done
in this sector again this is why so many
people
uh want to be you
really give me your husband awesome
um i want to hear more horror stories in
terms of
corporate media mistreatment of the
bernie's campaign
you're gonna get me in trouble look you
know it
it it was hard it was hard largely
because
you know i know that everybody who works
for every campaign
well i think that a lot of people who
work for a lot of campaigns really
believe they're in it for the right
reasons and
because their candidate is the one that
can truly help america and so i don't
mean to
sound like pollyanna about this now i
just want to interject for a moment brie
i cannot tell you how many times i did
an event
where there were uh tons of journalists
present
where i did what i thought was a good
job
and got zero mentioned
i know over and over again i i will tell
you that i told you this on our podcast
on bad faith podcast right i remember
being at the intercept and because i'm
so online i remember looking at youtube
videos i would see
i would be watching burning youtube
videos and see people from the yang gang
commenting in them
right like everywhere i looked on the
internet i saw yan gang yang and i was
like
this feels like an organic phenomenon
this feels like something
real and that's not going away in the
same way that i saw in a lot of youtube
comments
and twitter comments people who who were
from california who were from kamala
harris district
who were not big fans of her and i said
well this doesn't bode well for her
campaign i suspect that this is not
going to go well
it was an early indication of the fire
that you were able to
you ignite organically despite having no
participation
from the media and i remember getting a
request from your team
to see if the intercept had any interest
in profiling or interviewing you
and you know taking it to my editor and
like asking what he thought and
there was a kind of well this isn't
really going to go anywhere attitude and
and i don't say that to like throw any
under the anybody under the bus a lot of
people don't go anywhere and
i was i was going off of like youtube
comments and i could have very easily
been wrong
but i can perceive that there's a
certain kind of doom or pessimism
about new people and new ideas among the
left
that can sometimes hurt candidates that
could be really successful aoc barely
got any attention until she had that
viral um ad
in like spring of 2018 right so in your
case i think there are a lot of factors
i think that there's a hostility to new
people period
i think if i can say this there's a
certain amount of
you know like racist bias
frankly i i think that you mean the
asian thing
yeah i mean like they were like taking
inches off of your height and articles
they were like shrinking you down
a little bit odd the old the the old
incredible freaking candidate
was like huh i did it it was ridiculous
look
we haven't had a you know a large number
of examples of of american civilization
descent
like taking politics by storm that's not
a reason for you to ignore it's a reason
for you to celebrate first
the way that you do when a lot of other
firsts happen in this country and it was
really remarkable to me
you know pete buda judge being the first
openly gay candidate to run
is a big deal but why wasn't your first
status heralded more
we heard a lot about kamala harris's
first status
you know she's our first you know asian
american vp
or will be but you would have been our
first asian american president and
you can't pretend to care about these
identity things which are important
which i think
matter on a certain level but care
selectively because you're obviously
trying to boost
certain people's interests versus
another and that's why i think there's
so much cynicism
about identity politics and that's
ultimately destructive to a lot of
broader movements
um but yeah like i i i thought you
instantly were exciting largely because
you were bringing a new idea to the
table
new ideas to the table people you know
we all know that bernie sanders
you know isn't popular because he was
some like rhetorical dynamo
and he was like wowing everybody with
these obama-like speeches no
people were impressed with bernie
sanders because he stood on a stage
and said hey health care is a human
right
i don't think that you should die just
because you can't afford your
vision of values principles and goals
yes very very compelling and it's
unadulterated
until it's not poll tested you can tell
he actually believes
and you and you have some of that too
andrew like people
have a lot of resp respect for folks who
are willing to stand behind an idea
especially one that's not test driven or
pull
you know pole vetted or whatever and
just sell it
and there's not enough of innovation
there's not enough of
pitching that's done in the democratic
party there's too much pull testing and
saying well let's like fit ourselves in
the image of whatever this print sheet
of you know
printed out sheet of paper tells us to
be instead of having confidence in faith
in the american people to be able to
internalize
digest and adopt a new idea i'm going to
ask this just because i'm personally
curious
do you remember any uh conversations
on the campaign about universal basic
income and bernie
because i was waiting for him
to uh say something positive about
universal basic income really the
the whole time honestly do you remember
any of those conversations i was curious
i don't and i asked but i also wouldn't
have really been privy to them
in my role i will say that in the
discourse in the lefty discourse i've
noticed there's
um you know there's there's the jobs
guarantee camp and the ubi camp and
there's some like tension between them
and there's a lot of people who are like
i don't really care either or both good
ideas and i think
that what it felt like to me was that
bernie
with the jobs guarantee that was a part
of the green new deal
program had just decided maybe maybe for
messaging clarity reasons like this is
what we're going to do it's a green new
deal and jobs program the green new deal
and jobs program that's what we're going
to do
um but certainly now in the context of
covet
when you know bernie's been talking
about twelve hundred dollars a lot of
other people
went two thousand bill right and has
been since
the beginning right meanwhile and so has
kamala harris by the way
before she joined up with joe biden she
was championing two thousand dollars a
month relief
but now that she's a part of this ticket
has been silent on it and joe biden has
also been silent on
wildly silent and media has not pressed
him on this on whether or not he
supports cash relief so
i i think that in a lot of ways you won
the messaging battle
even if it took this horrible tragedy um
to get us there
i mean i wish that we weren't in these
circumstances uh that
accelerated enthusiasm for universal
basic income it's interesting hearing
your parallel
set of experiences with the media
where it blew my mind many many times
brie because like i'd be there like you
would have a conversation with a
journalist and then you'd be like oh
that was nice and then
um you know and then it'd be like you'd
do something and it's like it didn't
happen
[Laughter]
and in my case too i'll share this that
when i did get press coverage it was for
things that had nothing to do with um
what i was campaigning on most of the
time
it was for something very personality
driven uh like
like when i danced a cupid shuffle like
and then i showed up on the sunday news
programs that
weekend it was like me doing the cupid
shuffle as like uh
you know andrew yag like having a good
time on the trail sort of thing and i'm
like
huh yeah anyway
it's hard it it reminds me of this
conversation that's going on right now
all right about whether or not
the squad should use the fact that there
is a really narrow margin for democrats
in the house
to hold up nancy pelosi's floor vote
right if a very small number of
progressives could say
yes force the vote let's talk about
foreign um so they could make
make it so that nancy pelosi can't be
speaker of the house unless she concedes
to certain demands and what the main
demand that's being pushed right now is
that she
have a floor vote on medicare for all
and the idea being not because
there's a high likelihood that they that
we would win um that the house would
pass medicare for all
um they're only 118 co-sponsors in the
house now democrats have a majority and
they if
every democrat in the house would for
medicare for all we could pass medicare
for all and i think we should reflect
on what it means that all the house
democrats wouldn't pass medicare for all
in the middle of a global pandemic
that's a real i think indictment of
our politics right now but you know
there's this a lot of people are pushing
back against the idea saying well you're
not going to win anyway so what's the
point and it's all performative
well for a lot of us especially on the
left if you don't do something that can
grab attention if you don't do something
performant if you don't do the cupid
shuffle if you don't
figure out a way to marry the
performative and the substantive to say
force the vote
and let's hold hold up nancy pelosi
speakership let's let's
threaten nancy pelosi who uh you know
obviously politically
um because she is one of the least liked
her favorabilities are worse than trump
three quarters of americans think she
should
should sit down let's make step down
let's make her the center of the story
and also wet it with some substantive
policy goals let's get richard neal out
of the ways and means committee because
he's going to block medicare for all
let's get rid of pay go because that
stands in the way of us being able to
get all kinds of big ticket items that
pego requires you to fund them as you go
along and it makes it very difficult
um do we kind of put those things
together because the average american
doesn't want to hear a bunch of wonkery
about paygo
but they might be interested in nancy
pelosi right
and and vice versa and you gotta learn
how to do a stunt how to figure out how
to
exploit the system which is yes very
biased against the interest of the left
biased against the interest of of
working people
uh i like the idea of forcing the vote i
mean you know like you should be able to
vote on a policy that a lot of people
support and just
and if you if you're not for it then you
don't vote for it and then we know or
you know i mean
you know it's like it shouldn't be that
controversial in my mind um
well one thing i want to return to
because it speaks to this problem you're
describing right now and i think this is
one of the core things
so you said earlier that a bunch of
folks trust
liberal media um to report things with
good intentions and maybe they make
mistake every once in a while but
there's nothing sinister
afoot uh now
the trust in media and the trusted
institutions
actually changes dramatically
based upon your political alignment so
society-wide right now trusted media is
approximately 42 percent if you say hey
do you like trust national media to like
report the news like 42
not great that's not very not great it's
better than congress though
yeah congress is like 15 or something
like that right so
re-election rate of 94 though so that
that's a real problem
exactly hashtag right all that we could
get into
for sure so 42 of people trust the media
but it actually varies wildly
uh depending upon your politics uh it
turns out republicans do not trust the
media
at all more or less so you look at them
it's down to something like 24
you look at independence it's around the
42
whatever the national average is then
you look at democrats it's in the 60s
it's maybe like 62 percent
so what so what's happening is you have
uh democrats who are among the last
people that believe
that uh the media is getting it right
and that
the liberal media or as you'd call the
corporate news sources are getting it
right
and so there's like this conversation
that's being had
um that that folks uh
on really on on either side are feeling
someone excluded from like in in your
case the progressives like hey
is this really what's going on like my
guy just knocked it out of the park
the naacp like you might want to report
on that you know
like a lot of people like the idea of
giving everyone healthcare might want to
get behind that not treat everyone as
loony
who's for it uh and and then there are
folks on the
the right who have a different
perspective um
no i'm you know obviously more aligned
with with democrats
um but this institution non-institution
thing
is actually to me one of the most
powerful dynamics and the
media and the folks who trust the media
and trust that our institutions are
functioning
comprise the majority of the democratic
party uh
and and then there is this subset that i
think you are a part of that's starting
to question a lot of that and they're
like independent news media sources
there are some independent voices um but
it's difficult because there are a lot
of folks
who really do not want to question the
institutional
powers that be and to me the most
powerful example of that
which really blew my mind was before the
election
when uh they couldn't come to terms in a
relief bill
and uh steve mnuchin
i had like a 1.8 trillion dollar
offer that you you referenced earlier
and then
uh nancy did not want that deal for a
couple of reasons
and then i was looking around being like
why are people suggesting
should probably take this deal like
people are hurting we can't wait through
the winter
like let's just do this thing um and i
said
that and there were so few people
that were on board with my saying that
yeah i was like
yeah it was me and ro thank you rokhana
for not leaving me
all alone on this one um but there were
so many people that attacked me
oh yeah uh oh yeah
yeah you told me i was like look up like
i i have my
opinion on this negotiating stance like
i think you should probably jump on this
thing
uh you know and and you can disagree
with me you can say hey andrew
i think you're wrong um without it being
some kind of
like you know like uh attack and so
there was this thing
there's this thing that happened at
least to me and i think bernie for sure
but uh there was like this institutional
resistance
to so to someone uh questioning
nancy pelosi's uh process or judgment
um and it shocked me that there weren't
more people that were questioning it
at that point you know my friend
at every stage this is this is what
we're faced with look
i i expect that you probably got some
people accusing you of
secretly trying to support trump or why
do you hate the democratic party so much
you might as well go be a republican i
mean that's
that's the kind of response that i get
if i say anything mildly critical of a
choice made by a democrat
and in my case i was actually accused of
sexism that that was oh
there you go there's that's the talk
there's another one that happens look
obviously sexism is real and true in the
world but
it can't be this is again the cynicism
around identity politics
identity matters people have been
marginalized on the basis of their
identity
both socially and desure like legally
our government until
50 years ago was doing this identity
matters as a political metric
however identity cannot be cynically
used
by the party apparatus in order to
deflect substantive criticism
and the way that's being done repeatedly
and that cynicism around identity
is driving people to the right is
driving people into the arms of right
wingers that we
in in the you know neo-fascist populist
uprising that created trump in a way
that we don't want to happen we need to
be honest about what's going on and be
willing
to accept criticism so i think that you
were right about that i think that a lot
of people now that we see the deal that
we got
are understanding that a choice was made
explicitly
because nancy pelosi didn't want to give
donald trump
points anything that he could campaign
over before the election now
that raises a lot of other questions for
me why was the election so close
if donald trump was so vile right why
was the election so close that the idea
of letting him
put out a stimulus check with his name
on it could have thrown
maybe we don't even know that that's
true but maybe could have advantaged him
meaningfully in the election
why wasn't the democratic party long
before we got that close to the price to
the general election
running explicitly on cash payments to
americans why wasn't that
arms favored by 88 of voters i don't
know what the other 12
are thinking uh 88 is pretty high
yes by the way you know what else 88 of
voters support
medicare for all 88 of voters support no
sorry 88
of democrats support medicare for all 72
percent of voters according to a fox
news exit poll a fox news exit poll
should that 72 percent of americans
overall support medicare for all
and about 50 of republicans do so why is
it that
joe biden is in in the context of the
general election saying
i would veto medicare for all even if it
passed the house in the senate why is
why aren't we asking the questions about
why the democrats are
running on these enormously popular
beneficial policies
that can make the election not so close
that we had to deny
americans much needed economic support
at a national low point in terms of both
the economy and our national health
the the lack of stimulus between
april and december was
it's morally yeah like morally criminal
you know like looking at that
objectively
be like and if you withheld for
political reasons
um that's awful and
you know you can't know whether that was
the motivation but certainly
it felt a whole lot like that they said
at one point
they it was made explicit at one point
that you know this could this could help
trump like that was an explicit message
i don't remember at this point
don't quote me that it came out of
pelosi's mouth or somebody else in
democratic party leadership
but that wasn't a creation of the media
that wasn't just conjecture that that
was the message
and democrats you know a lot of
democrats who trust the party bought
into that and said
well yes the most important thing is
defeating donald trump therefore
even if it hurts millions of americans
were going to keep the stimulus in the
bag
and you know that that's that's why i'm
saying again like it should never have
been that close whether or not it helps
donald trump was only an issue because
i believe the the party leadership in
in the the chosen candidate didn't do
enough to distinguish themselves for
trump and fight affirmatively
for what they were going to do for
america instead it was i'm not trump
let's defeat trump's sort of campaign
and that just doesn't galvanize people
the way that cash relief
medicare for all canceling student debt
legalizing marijuana
ubi mobilizes people
so bree uh now that and i remember
the the spring very well and i know it
was deeply painful for everyone on the
bernie campaign where it felt like it
was this
close like right there post nevada and
then
um jim climber endorses joe in south
carolina and then the entire tide turns
and all the candidates
um
had a particular direction
so it's been seven eight months since
then you've now pivoted to become
an independent voice a journalist you're
producing things that you believe in
what do you see
as like the next number of steps uh for
progressives for trying to make some of
these
changes happen politically for yourself
individually
you know i mean you've had like a
fascinating career already and you're
still
just getting started um but like i i
look up and
you know there are times when i'm very
optimistic um there are times when i
think that the mechanics of our system
are just desperately broken uh and that
uh and when you start digging into some
of these numbers like
you know an 18 approval rating for
congress and a 94
reelection rate you're like whoa like
how does that work and then you you
start
looking at mechanical fixes um one
mechanical fix i've been pushing very
hard is ranked choice voting
and open primaries which i think would
uh make our politics much more dynamic
and responsive
and genuine and then you can you
couldn't bully everyone being like
you're going to waste your vote
you're going to like elect the evil or
whatever it's like well if you're ranked
as voting we don't need to worry about
it anymore so
let's pursue true democratic reforms
yeah i i'm a huge fan a huge advocate of
ranked choice voting
um the number one bully pull put to your
point the democratic party has is
if you don't vote for the lesser of two
evils you're going to make the evil win
and we have been operating on that logic
since you know realignment and the
democratic
party became what it is today um in the
republican party
became the you know southern strategy
party of
of uh white racism that you know it
emerged as
and we've been trying to struggle out of
that since the 1960s
since the 1950s and uh
i raised this question you know at this
point kind of infamously
on our podcast in an episode with noam
chomsky where i i simply asked look
let's assume that donald trump presents
a unique evil and we all have to vote
him out this time
what do we do between now and 2024 to
make sure we're not in the same
situation how do we get out of this
lesser of two legalism structure
and if we are willing to pledge our
votes the democratic party no matter
what under any circumstances
i you know i thought michael bloomberg
um was a closer call in terms of who was
worse with respect to donald trump
because he's a lot more capable
and has actually enacted had actually
enacted a much more extreme
racial pogrom in new york city than
donald trump managed although he
certainly tried
um because michael bloomberg is an
incompetent unlike donald trump
um and people were you know willing to
vote for him
you know there were donnie joyce people
were saying they wouldn't vote for
bernie but they would vote for for
bloomberg if he was the eventual nominee
so what authority do we have what what
line in the stand
can we is there if if the democrat if
democrats are never willing to say
enough is enough this is not the kind of
candidate we want representing us this
is not the kind of party we are
is there any policy that they won't
throw under the bus is there any kind of
candidate that we won't accept
and if the answer is no we're go we
should expect that the party moves more
and more and more to the right over the
course of history
the way it's been doing so what's going
to stop that movement i think that
ranked choice voting is one of those
things
i think greater union participation in
figuring out how to organize
massive blocks of voters that can
meaningfully incredibly threaten
democrats to say we are going to
withhold our vote we are not going to
mobilize our population
unless you adhere to some basic
standards like the fact that 88
of democrats want medicare for all but
barely half of the house of
representatives
will co-sponsor the bill
what that the idea the idea people
people
are arguing against forced to vote who
are like well it wouldn't pass anyway
that's not an indictment of the idea of
forced to vote that's a
colossal indictment of elected
representatives
democratic representatives in the house
we are in the middle of a global
pandemic where
15 million people have just lost their
employer-based healthcare
all of the people who are arguing if you
like your healthcare you can keep it
during the primary election should be
put on the mat
by a journalist every single day asking
have you revised your
position do you want to apologize for
misleading the public and spreading
right-wing talking points because none
of that was true and now you have to
answer to
15 million americans 15 million
who in the middle of a global health
crisis have no recourse
with respect to paying for their health
care that's unconscionable
and yet we don't have a media apparatus
who's willing to do that
and for people like you and those in the
left who are willing to stand up and
articulate
some you know break from consensus
are ridiculed called traitors to the
party
accused of sexism or some other kind of
identity based bias
and there's no real reckoning at any
point so i do think that yes
ranked choice voting needs to be pushed
democrats will never do it because
that's the source
one of the main sources of their power
but we have to agitate for it
um we need to start going to town halls
take a lesson out of the tea parties
playbook which is was a lesson out of
salalinsky's playbook on the left
and make life uncomfortable for our
elected representatives until they
start actually representing us and that
goes for some of the people who have
been progressive champions as well it's
not about throwing them out
or saying they're terrible people or
questioning their motives
but it's about understanding that there
is a such thing as institutional creep
um when you are in office your motives
start to change
and you have an incentive in maintaining
your status and your position
and you have all these incentives to
raise money and and give money to the
parties that you can get
hierarchy and status within your
committee positions and all these kinds
of things which are important
but shouldn't come at the expense of the
people that you were elected to
represent
we need to give money to independent
candidates so that they can rely on the
people and be beholden to the people
instead of being beholden to
corporate interests we need to push for
campaign finance reform so they don't
have the option
to be dependent on corporate interests
and we all just have to stay a lot more
engaged and have
confidence have faith keep the faith
that if we do these things and we stand
together and we recognize that it's not
left right that it is top down
and the 99 stands together it is
possible for us to have a better world
it is possible and we should not let
pessimism cow
oh you're like the antidote to cynicism
i love it anyone
anyone who needs needs a reminder
of the the fact that we can do great
things
uh brie's got a podcast every every week
with
virgil who's more of a virgo's more of a
downer than bree so you guys know
there's a little bit of a
yin-yang good bad cop situation
oh yeah there you are you're a very good
team um so for you personally
i'm sure there was like a sense of
depletion
after the campaign and then you've just
gotten kind of your
legs underneath you in terms of this
new podcast and your new independent
media project
would the plan be to just keep on uh
building your um voice and work until
like the
the next candidate catches fire and
manages to get your attention
yeah i mean certainly i'm interested to
see what happens electorally but i'm
also
really interested to start to explore
non-electoral activism you know
there's been a little bit of a circular
firing squad on the left this past week
or two about force the vote
and to try to break out of that i'm
reaching out to
union leaders and organizers to try to
come on and give us a more
um concrete sense of how change happens
you know
a lot of left pundits like to say well
your idea doesn't work because it really
requires organizing it requires
grassroots support i mean like that's
great but don't we play a role in
helping to germinate that
can't we do that why not right like i'm
not doing anything else i'm just a
podcaster let me let me call up the head
of my local dsa
let me write to my representative and
see if she
she can get on the record on for us to
vote you know let let me
reach out to the medicare for all
advocates let me reach out to black
lives matter advocates
let's see what does it actually take to
get 3 000 people sitting in front of the
capitol what does it take to organize
a million person march or the women's
march let me let me ask um
you know this woman not doing anything
this woman can do anything she doesn't
date
it's beautiful well i haven't done it
yet one thing i want
oh yo you you you will do um all of
those things are very doable
one thing i want to just insert into
this forced to vote conversation
and this is something that a member of
congress informed me of that i was like
wow that's freaking
terrible um is it's very hard to get any
vote going
on the floor because of something called
the denny hastert rule
where you need the majority of the
majority party to be on board
to even introduce anything so i want you
all to
imagine being first let's say a minority
legislator so let's say you're
a democrat the senator or republican in
the house you're like well i can't force
a vote on a single thing
maybe because we're not we're not a
majority of the majority
and then i want you to imagine being a
minority of the majority party where you
also can't
get a vote on anything uh because you
know like you you don't have
i suppose it would be um you know like a
hundred and
uh 30 or 140 colleagues on board or
whatever the number is
um so that rule just strikes me is so
terrible like it just seems like such a
dysfunctional body where it's literally
like if you have the majority of the
majority then you can
actually advance things and if you don't
you can't and then
you can just chill out like like yeah
so it is an action which is why this
opportunity
right because the speaker can bring a
floor vote the speaker regardless of
the numbers you've got can bring us four
votes well the speaker is the one that
enacted this rule that's not even a rule
it's like you know it's like the speaker
saying well i'm not going to do it
unless the majority majority so they
clearly can do what they want yeah and
it's an aggregating party for
herself a power rather for herself all
of it so much of what we see in politics
is that people get
a little bit of power and they hoard it
you know even you know we talked a lot
about
george bush's overreach and expansion of
executive power
and then barack obama came into office
and instead of dismantling it once you
get there like well i'm the good guy
so it's good if i have power so let me
keep let me keep what was aggregated for
me in the last administration and then
get a little bit more
and so what we get is increasingly
individuals
who are able to lord their preferences
in a very anti-democratic way over the
rest of us
which i'm going to suggest is
particularly problematic when you're
looking at
legislative body of hundreds of people
like that
that to me is like more problematic even
i mean
the executive abuses have their own uh
you know like separate category of
problem but i feel like in a legislative
body like hoarding it at that level just
seems particularly
um egregious at least to me
yeah i mean they're supposed they're
literally it's it's especially the house
that kind of representative body the
most representative body that we
have basically being frozen
in an action you know in this idea that
you know to your point about republicans
not being able to bring something to a
floor vote too
look what's happening right now who
who's fighting for cash relief
it's a it's a independent and a
republican
you know um you know who are who are
leading the chart bernie's
you know so it was in the senate it was
bernie sanders
and josh hawley exactly and then there
were some folks working it
behind the scenes including cory booker
and then i know this because i've been
actually working this scene for
a while like i've been having
calls and sessions about cash relief and
then uh
and then in the house i'm happy to say
that dozens of
um members on both sides of the aisle
uh got on board with with cash relief
and so there was like this four corners
negotiation around the stimulus bill
if you remember the bipartisan senate
bill that got proposed in the beginning
of december didn't include cash relief
and we had like a freak out here i had a
freak out i was like how can there not
be cash relief in this thing
um but we've been trying to get folks
excited about cash
as um part of this bill for weeks
and so i'm just going to call out a few
people some of whom you know and love
but uh lisa blunt rochester and david
mckinley were the bipartisan sponsors of
a cash leap bill in the house
and then i'm happy to say that like
people from all over the political map
from
pramila jayapal to uh to tom reed to
others and one of the rules we had on
that bill
was that we want a republican for every
democrat um and we got it
like so it just like it grew it was like
noah's ark
it was wild um but but but so you should
know that that was happening in the
house the house i think was more
um uh stridently for cash relief
in the senate it blew my mind that after
bernie and josh hawley came out and like
hey we should really have stimulus which
they were totally right
um and and i was working like senators
being like you want to get in on that
because they're right and like you know
like everyone agrees with it
um and so it was odd that we couldn't
get more senators on the record
um for cash relief uh there were three
that were
for it behind the scenes anyway sorry
just one month
that's really useful and i think that
part of it is that they're not as
senators aren't as accountable you know
they have longer terms
um their races tend to be uh more
expensive
you know um i think they can
in a lot of ways be less less
accountable to their constituents plus
to the earlier point about
uh media bias i don't know if you saw
the clip where bernie sanders
you know went on msnbc to talk about
um cash relief and he was pressed by i
believe it was stephanie rule
she said well i'm looking at a sheet of
paper here bernie she had a graphic all
ready to go that says you've only passed
whatever the handful of uh bills and
your entire
time in congress don't you think you
should take a different approach
so she completely took the conversation
off of this relief bill and millions of
americans who desperately need it
to try to give some dig about how she
doesn't think that bernie sanders has
done enough while he is in congress and
like that's the kind of crap you get
and and people get away with it people
get away with it
i mean i certainly have an axe to grind
with msnbc i don't know
i don't i don't know if you were
surprised of the entire
like uh dynamic over there i saw it
happening i saw you
you know all the little stuff not
cutting to you during
the debates you know like it was it was
apparent to me
you know it was apparent to me what was
happening to you what was happening to
marianne williamson
um you know before like a second there
like
build a block like i had my eyes open
um and i don't think it behooves us even
if it were to like advantage my
candidate i don't think it behooves us
in the long term for us to um
ignore those things because it hurt
every candidate at a certain point right
there was a point at which
um uh corey cory booker
and julian castro both raised concerns
about whether or not joe biden had the
stamina to be president
and in the spin room
they were kind of immediately shut down
the coverage of julian castro asking
that question during the debate of like
did you just
you know forget what you just said was
really
pilloried even though if you listen back
to the tape he was completely right you
cannot disagree with his tone or
something but he was accurate
in his assessment of what had just
happened on the stage and then
the the little the statement the mild
you know
cory booker is so polite he gave a
really soft mild you know like i'm just
concerned like it's something that we
should consider
you never heard a peep out of them ever
again the back it was
it was like a hard shut down we're not
gonna talk about joe biden's
um you know stamina anything cognitive
and we're just gonna
we're gonna push for like this never
happened and then the idea that anyone
would question
whether joe biden's you know little
peccadillos here and there
were a part of or an indication of
something bigger that was going on
it was it was fun as this is a left-wing
attack i'm like
you know cory booker is
it's not exactly what i would call left
wing he's like a lovely man
but he's this is not exactly what i
would call a part of the left vanguard
you know and so this kind of stuff adds
up and it doesn't help people not to
have
conversations that are gonna emerge in
the general because donald trump isn't
playing by those rules
vetted in a primary when we can still do
something about it
this is something um that's come out
recently about diane
fein feinstein yes yes um
no and um the average
age of a u.s senator is 62 and that's
average
so you know and to me age is just a
number but they're like some folks that
like are are um
feeling their age and others that are
less so and so you know if there's some
kind of
way to verify what i mean i certainly
think trump's been freaking
deteriorating before our eyes
last over the last number of years um so
this to me is i actually something that
the media
um should be considered like really much
more responsible for
um that we are not uh it it's like
uh that that um we have
leaders who um would not
be considered for leadership positions
in other industries
based upon their um their age and then
in the public sector it's like a taboo
subject to raise
um in various ways just age like you
know obviously i supported a very old
candidate
you know and you know as much as i felt
like it was biased and sometimes not
constructive
i'm not going to be mad at anyone for
having a conversation about you know
does bernie have the stamina after a
heart attack like that's a legitimate
conversation to have
but the bias the unwillingness to have
that conversation about joe biden
you know the unwillingness to have a
conversation you know
in light of specific instances of him
misspeaking or getting facts wrong or
having
an emotional outburst at a reporter
listen
fat pushing people you know like this
this stuff is
fair game if it's going to be fair game
about other candidates
and the idea that it could be spun into
a left-wing attack it's just it's
it boggles the mind yeah that should be
there should just be a standard
even stevens that's all i ask yeah
um wow this is so much fun i can't
believe
that time has flown by we should do this
every week
i'm going to urge you to replace virgil
with me
let's let's go to podcast
at that point i would i would have to
like answer for why
i only do podcasts with asian american
men
or something about it i didn't know
pre-virgil there was another though
no like my first oh wait you saw you
told me yes
that's right wow
no wonder you know this feels so
familiar
um but incredibly grateful to you
um really and learned a lot you are such
a positive voice of both reason and
progress
i appreciate the heck out of you if
there's anything i can do to help let me
know
um and certainly let virgil know that if
he needs me to pinch hit for him anytime
show up unannounced i appreciate that
and i appreciate you two so much andrew
you're a clarion voice
and i appreciate your willingness to
kind of go against the grain and i
really look forward to
whatever is up your sleeve next as well
thank you bri
so much fun have a great holiday season
you too stay safe
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
you